à saint denis de jouhet petites communes
rurales des habitants ont la chance
d'avoir un cabinet médical mis en place
par la communauté de communes
d'aigurande et un médecin installé
depuis un peu moins de deux ans hongrois
d'origine ayant exercé en roumanie
le docteur matt et s'est lancé dans une
aventure qu'il ne regrette pas pour
commencer l'activité c'est nécessaire
tout le temps beaucoup de deux aides
bon le maire des fois c'est 13 heures il
est très très important pour fait tout
ce qui est nécessaire même de parler
avec les passions sa plus proche voisine
pharmacienne de son état s'est beaucoup
investi pour réussir cette installation
en utilisant notamment le dispositif
départemental dead puis aussi adjointe à
la mairie
et donc on a aidé de par la mairie à
l'installation par une prise en charge
de ces loyers professionnelles
personnelles par l'achat de matériel
comme on a aidé aussi le cne qui est
venu ultérieurement il départements
l'ain re a pris en charge oscille à une
aide substantielle à l'installation
l'utilisation des réseaux et la mise en
commun d'informations - suivi du jeune
stagiaire médecins participent aussi à
ce léger frémissement de reprise nous y
mettons tous ensemble depuis deux ans
c'est la première fois première année où
le nombre de médecins ne baisse plus
parce qu on a suffisamment d'arrivée
pour compenser les départs et pourtant
père des caisses médecins par an eh bien
les derniers étant sa crainte de nous
sommes à 147 même si on est loin d'une
véritable reprise des installations
l'hémorragie de médecins dans l'indre
s'est arrêté il faut maintenant
convaincre les jeunes de venir exercer
car la population médicale est
vieillissante et espère pouvoir
transmettre rapidement le flambeau